foreign
then you're familiar with the lengths
people will go to deny objective reality
I asked one young woman in the film what
would happen if my truth was that she no
longer existed and she immediately
replied that uh if that's my truth that
that she doesn't exist well then she
doesn't exist
such was her commitment to the
relativistic viewpoint but since the two
of us were standing in the same physical
environment and having that conversation
in the first place
does that not indicate that there is
some sort of shared reality that we both
inhabit and since that reality has
certain laws certain immutable features
does that not again indicate that there
is one truth one reality filled with
lots of people who all Harbor ideas and
opinions which may or may not comport
with that reality
that's not what is that what it means I
mean after all no matter what your truth
might be we all still live in a world
where two plus two equals four
or do we Ontario math teacher Heather
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna even attempt
the last name thighs buyer thymeyer
Maybe
well whatever uh she says otherwise in a
tweet reposted by Chris Ruffo Heather
who again teaches math to kids
wrote quote there are many math
education practices that we white folk
don't see as racist or supremacist
because they're so ingrained in our
background and experiences and we've
been the ones to benefit from them she
then thanked someone named Jason too for
shining a light on these examples of
mathematical racism she then provides a
chart in the shape of a pyramid
which distinguishes between overt white
supremacy in math education and then
below that she has covert white
supremacy in math education now examples
of overt white supremacy are things like
racially segregated classrooms
which by the way is something that only
the left actually supports anyway and
also she says the n-word uh the n-word
is is an example of overt white
supremacy which is a good tip for any
Math teachers out there do not
incorporate the n-word into your math
instruction
just so you know don't do that if you
find yourself shouting the n-word while
teaching long division
something has gone horribly wrong
Heather points out and I'm glad that
she's here to clarify that point but
then we move to the covert examples
and there we find a bit of a mixed bag
so she says that standardized testing is
white supremacy which is good news for
me because I always did very poorly on
standardized tests as a kid which I
guess means that I'm not a white
supremacist
of course there are many valid
criticisms you could make of the
standardized testing approach and
especially if a system structured around
standardized testing but people like
Heather make those conversations
Impossible by insisting on racializing
everything as always
she also says that the phrase um stick
to math is white supremacy and we could
maybe spend some time reflecting on how
stupid that is but we have bigger fish
to fry because she also lists two plus
two equals four
as white supremacy
yes only in a white supremacist Fantasy
Land do two things and two other things
equal four things
if it wasn't for white supremacy two
apples and two apples would make nine
apples or 12 apples or three apples in
Orange and five coconuts two and two
apples would be a whole fruit salad if
not for white supremacy
now if this seems to make no sense at
all
that's because it doesn't make any sense
but I think In fairness I should let The
Advocates of this idea explain it for
themselves unfortunately the teacher who
posted this tweet locked down her
account so we don't know what else she
has to say the guy she credits for
having shed light on this
um Jason too I went to his account to
see if he's explained it
and he in fact said that he's um he's
not going to explain why two plus two
equals racism
he says we should all simply accept it I
guess because he said so
he did however retweet a different math
teacher by the name of Lori of Laurie
rubell who posted a thread on the
subject and here's what she said
what does the two plus two equal four
talk mean here we go again
she then posts a meme and explains in
the caption here's one way that two plus
two equals 4 gets used a crowd of people
has gathered holding signs with various
alternative equations the one guy who
apparently knows the truth is being
excluded slash derided and called a Nazi
that image isn't actually about math
it's about truth who holds the truth who
decides what is true and how open are we
as a society to multiple truths
does this mean that anything goes no it
does not
here's another Insidious way that two
plus two equals four gets used it's used
as a kind of basic truth and way to
ridicule many critiques of mathematics
as white and Western and as exclusionary
are those critiques suggesting literally
that two plus two is anything other than
four no
okay so then what does it suggest I mean
what do you what the hell are these
people babbling about well if you are
like so many people in our culture uh
desperate for validation and respect
then I've got one way you can achieve
that uh it's with established titles now
established titles is your opportunity
to earn the title of Lord or lady and
gain the respect that you deserve all
you need is a one square foot plot of
land in Scotland it's all takes in your
title pack you'll be bestowed with at
least one square foot of dedicated land
on a private estate in edelston Scotland
plus an official certificate with a
Crest as you can see I have mine here
which I usually proudly display uh in my
studio ear certificate features a unique
plot Number with uh which you can see
the exact location of your land and you
can even go and I guess probably stand
on it if you want to title packs from
established titles are a fun and unique
gift for any occasion and there are even
couple packs that come with adjoining
plots of land for the special someone in
your life with your certificate you
could officially add the prefix of Lord
or lady to your credit card to your
plane tickets even your dating profiles
most importantly and get this
established titles told me that the
first 200 people purchasing a title pack
using my exclusive link will receive a
plot within a few walking minutes of
mine so depending on how many of us
become Lords and Ladies we can build our
own kingdom established titles is
actually running a massive sale right
now plus if you use the code wall should
get an additional 10 off so it's a lot
of incentive all you got to do is go to
establishtitles.com Walsh to get your
gifts now and help support the channel
well Laurie then links to a different
thread that she wrote on the same topic
about a year ago which tells us this
the two plus two equals four talk
signals that there is a single truth a
single way of looking at things a single
correct way to live or be rather than
multiplicities of all of these matters
since math is endowed with social
Authority and positioned as objective
and as part of a natural order
that then implies that the singular
approach is also part of the natural
order that's why people reference two
plus two equals four in racist
anti-trans anti-queer talk Etc because
in their view opening up Math and how we
teach it would imply a challenge to a
natural order they hold a sacred one in
which white people and usually men are
at the helm
okay so in other words they can't
explain why two plus two equals four uh
it means racism because the claim is
abject nonsense
well it always goes with these academics
like they make some absolutely
ridiculous statement and then either
refuse to explain it insisting that
their mere assertion should be good
enough for us that we should bow before
them intellectually and accept whatever
tribe spews from their pompous
self-satisfied mouths or else they
pretend to explain it but in reality
they're simply just talking around the
issue going off in half a dozen
different directions and at the end of
it all we're left with an assertion
layered in a bunch of other assertions
with nothing in the way of an argument
much less a proof or evidence to be
found
now in this case there are really two
claims being made
one is that there is no objective truth
and two is that asserting an objective
truth is racist
and they don't explain either assertion
and of course they don't actually
believe either of them either
because if they did for one thing they
couldn't possibly teach mathematics
every this is the whole point of
bringing up two plus two equals four in
order to explain that objective truth
exists because every math lesson would
consist of them just sitting in front of
the class and saying whatever you think
is true is true you all get A's
congratulations
now we may be getting to the point where
school will be taught that way but we
aren't quite there yet which means that
they do believe in objective truth if
they teach math to teach something means
that you believe that there is an
objective truth to be taught the very
Act of teaching means that you are
affirming that there is a truth
because if there isn't that means that
you're just what trying to get the kids
to accept whatever subjective point of
view you have
what's the point of that that seems a
highly uh egotistical
also I'm willing to bet that if either
of our friends Laurie or Heather ever
encountered say an actual white
supremacist I mean a real one like an
actual klansman
one of the four who exist in the country
would they not be willing to agree that
the guy's worldview is true on on any
level I mean would they affirm his
worldview
would they give him the benefit of of
his own truth
no they wouldn't in fact they would
insist that he is both factually and
morally wrong about everything he
believes
and they would condemn him accordingly
the only way that you can condemn
someone for their worldview or their
racism or bigotry is if you are
asserting some factual and moral truth
that you expect them to comport to and
conform themselves to
in fact
um they even for people who aren't
klansmen
they'll do this the very statement
two plus two equals four is white
supremacy that in and of itself is an
assertion of Truth
everything you heard in the explanation
wasn't absurd as an assertion of Truth
and it all rests on the belief that
white supremacy whatever it is is bad
which is also an assertion of Truth
so they do believe that there is a truth
there's an objective truth a reality
that we all inhabit
which has not only scientific and
physical laws but even moral laws
it's just that they're very selective in
who should be forced to abide by these
laws
so this is racial paternalism cloaked
and so-called anti-racism which is to
say it's just anti-racism because that's
all anti-racism ever is
now
briefly leaving aside the problem that
these people don't actually believe
anything that they're saying
and also the problem that you can't deny
objective truth without asserting it at
the same time
because saying there is no objective
truth is an assertion of an objective
truth so but leaving all that aside
I want to focus
um on on one thing Lori says in her
explanation
again quoting the two plus two equals
four talk signals that there is a single
truth a single way of looking at things
a single correct way to live or be
rather than multiplicities of all these
matters well right this is exactly the
problem
she says that two plus two equals four
signals that there's a single truth well
yeah it does and that's the point
there's one single truth and in that
truth which is the only truth two things
combined with two other things make four
things
but then she goes on and says that there
that it also signals that there is one
way of looking at things and one correct
way to live
but it doesn't signal that at all
and and the truth the the way we look at
things and the way we live these are
three categories they're not all the
same
they don't belong in the same category
the truth is just the truth it's the
reality it's the state of things
that's what the truth is
and it persists it maintains no matter
what we think or how we live
as far as as far as what we think and
how we live we have lots of freedom in
that regard not complete freedom
I I can't live at the bottom of the
ocean I can't live on the moon
the reason I can't live that way is that
physical reality otherwise known as the
truth precludes it but within certain
parameters I can live basically how I
want and I can certainly think what I
want yet I cannot
through the power of my thought
or the manner of my lifestyle change the
fundamental facts of reality I can
choose to acknowledge those realities or
not
but the realities persist
this is how the relativists play the
game they conflate reality with
perspective and lifestyle they assert
that because there's a multiplicity of
perspectives and Lifestyles there must
also be a multiplicity of realities but
then of course by trying to create more
realities they actually erase the
multiplicities of perspectives
because what they're actually asserting
is that each reality has has only one
perspective and if you have another
perspective then you exist in a
completely different reality
what they're saying is that in in this
the reality that I'm in there's only one
perspective anyone anyone has a
different perspective and that they they
Branch off to their own we live in this
Multiverse and uh and each Multiverse
each little universe of the Multiverse
is populated by one person
you only get one perspective for each
universe
information
the relativists cannot explain their
arguments they can't defend to prove
them
they don't even mean most of what
they're saying and they can't help but
contradict themselves a dozen times in
one sentence
it's a mess in other words
and it is why they are all today
canceled
well I hope you enjoyed that clip from
Matt Walsh show if you did be sure to
subscribe to this YouTube channel and
click the notification button to get
more content like this if you want to
watch or listen to the full show head to
dailywire.com And subscribe today you
can also listen to my podcast on Spotify
Apple podcast or wherever you get your
podcasts